[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
رغم اعلان طرفي المعارك في السودان
موافقتهما على هدنه جديده بدات فجرا اليوم
اشتباكات في محيط القصر الرئاسي ووسط
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري الجيش السوداني
اكيد انه قلاص قدرات الدعم السريع
القتاليه باكثر من النصف وقوه دعم تقول
انها لا تزال تسيطر على مواقع في القصر
الرئاسي ومقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون ومطار
الخرطوم على صعيد السياسي المبعوث الامامي
الى السودان يعلن موافقه طرفي النزاع على
ارسال موفدين لمحادثات محتمله في السعوديه
لبحث وقف دائم لاطلاق النار على صعيد
الانساني الامم المتحده تعلن وقت العمليات
مؤقتا في بعض مناطق السودان بما فيها
الخرطوم وتؤكد ان امتداد الازمه السودانيه
الى دول اخرى مبعث قلق كبير وسط خلاف بين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وشركه فاجنر بشان بخ
القوات الروسيه تقول انها قصفت مواقع
عسكريه اوكرانيه وتواصل تقدمها في بخموت
والجيش الاوكراني يؤكد ان القوات الروسيه
فشلت في السيطره على المدينه بعد اعتقال
دام نحو اربع سنوات السلطات المصريه تخلي
سبيل الزميل هشام عبد العزيز الصحفي بقناه
الجزيره مباشر واكدت اسره زميل هشام تنفيذ
قرار اخلاء سبيله ووصوله الى منزله في
القاهره
الى اللقاء